Fateci largo che passamo noi
sti giovanotti de' sta roba bella dietro
una vacca aspettavamo stretti che
arrivasse a sensore che siamo mai visto
in Silence One Direction
My name is Giovanni Giorgio e aveva di
Cosmi Giorgio
ma partire
Finger momentaneo non abbiamo Vabbè
Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij e
quelle che avete sentito poco fa sono
delle canzoni che probabilmente voi
conoscerete però con la mia voce ma io
non le ho mai mai cantate realmente
queste canzoni e Perché c'hanno la mia
voce vi lascio al video e buona visione
Era da un po' che non mi capitava di
fare un video molto scazzo per quanto
l'argomento non lo sia per niente però
mi trovo quelle mattine in cui di
lavoricchio Io lavoro ogni tanto che mi
ha distratto oggi oltre i limiti di età
che mi sono stati imposti sul video di
Outlast c'è una cosa incredibile Allora
io sono molto affascinato di come
l'intelligenza artificiale stia
progressivamente
migliorando ehm di giorno giorno Insomma
stanno facendo un sacco di update voi
avete cliccato questo video giustamente
perché avete visto che l'intelligenza
artificiale riesce ad emulare la voce di
cantanti di persone conosciute e che
quindi si possono creare proprio delle
vere e proprie canzoni con la voce di
qualcun altro Qualcuno ha fatto la mia
ha messo la mia voce disponibile per
poterla afficcare nelle cose in giro Non
che io ne sappia niente però a quanto
pare esiste ed è qua la vedete questo
server discord si chiama ihab è uno dei
tanti posti dove ci sono le voci se uno
mette the weekend ci sarà sicuramente la
voce di the weekend Eccola qua ce ne
sono anche di più tra l'altro per
esempio ci sono dei cantanti che magari
hanno avuto una carriera lunga e quindi
ci sono magari hanno modificato
leggermente la loro voce nel corso della
carriera Perché Vabbè si cresce si
cambia si cambiano le modulazioni vocali
ci sono anche più versioni dello stesso
cantanti Favij ce n'è una che io non ho
idea di come sia possibile queste qua
Ciao amici di Jay Hub sono Favij
Ragazzi io non ho mai detto questa cosa
nella mia vita a questa è la preview
Ciao amici di ayhab sono Favij No vabbè
no Ma ragazzi incredibile Quindi cosa ho
pensato di fare in questo video testiamo
La mia voce sei ficcata in delle canzoni
questo video sarà copiato Probabilmente
sì mi piace lavorare gratis ultimamente
non so se capito Allora ragazzi Qua c'è
tutto il tutorial che devo seguire
adesso non so farvi vedere tutta sta
roba raga perché sennò ci metto un'ora
ci metterò un'ora e mezza a fare sta
roba perché non mi sembra neanche
semplicissimo vi faccio vedere
direttamente alla fine Beati voi che vi
schippate sta parte Va bene ok ragazzi
sono arrivato a un buon punto
teoricamente adesso per fare questa cosa
devi convertire solo la parte vocale di
un pezzo musicale con la voce che hai
selezionato quindi sostanzialmente se io
prendo starboy di the weekend devo
togliere la parte vocale quindi questa
sparizione
seleziono Favij da qua e ficco quella di
The weeknd qui la mia ragazzi c'è questa
cosa non ha senso e poi bisogna fare
convert teoricamente te lo dovrebbe
tirar fuori carica l'audio E adesso
dovremmo avere il file io non so dove
stiamo andando a finire ve lo giuro sto
per aprirlo eh Invece Io che canto
starboy Va bene
mi sa che Miami
[Musica]
Raga ma che cazzo dite Ma com'è
possibile ma questa cosa non ha senso
secondo me sta roba si può avere un
effetto Maggiore se io in questo caso mi
ficco su qualcuno che ha una voce simile
alla mia perché se tu ovviamente se io
mi metto sulla voce di Rihanna Comunque
lui cerca di trasformare la voce
originale nella mia però se è troppo
distante vocalmente Secondo me l'effetto
è meno potente facciamo un esempio
andiamo a mettere mi sento un video di
surry no perché si può fare con tutto
sta roba a sto punto Signore e signori
Buona serata queste mancatita Io sono
surry iniziamo qualche leggettino Non
esattamente piacevole ma va bene così
allora che Buongiorno La nostra età che
c'è un po' di elenco in questo episodio
Come anticipavo nella scorsa puntata
sembra che sto facendo il vocione capito
Eh ma allora ok Raga ho provato Stronger
di Kanye West vediamo perché viene
ucciso
song anni giurano via Tesa anche due in
my song sono cose futuristiche questo
Cioè Incredibile ho fatto anche staya a
questo punto giusto per il meme
[Musica]
a fare questa e ormai è la più semplice
Ragazzi mi sono svegliato stamattina e
ho fatto questo Beh fantastico Spero che
vi sia piaciuto Fatemi sapere cosa ne
pensate di questa evoluzione tecnologica
No più che altro ci sono delle robe
assurde Cioè veramente quella roba che
tu puoi parlare in un videogioco con un
npc ti risponde a cazzate che dici c'è
questa cosa è fuori di testa raga Cioè
non so se fare un Gameplay Potrei
provare a fare un Gameplay su sta roba
per vedere che succede Boh Fatemi sapere
ragazzi che ne pensate Noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video lasciate un bel commento
mi piace e niente Ciao
Co co Conad vicino guaglione Show
[Applauso]
you wanna do no
[Musica]